j'ai trouvé une dernière bobine de la
série il toujours voir l'invisible donc
bah voilà c'est la dernière de l'été bon
visionnage
[Musique]
bienvenue fidèle spectatrice spectateurs
dans ce nouvel épisode des corses de
recherche consacrés au monde mystérieux
de l'invisible
avec vu les mouvements de l'air
provoquée par les gesticulations
non car l'air est parfaitement
transparent
est ce que vous arrivez à voir les
turbulences provoquées
lorsque j'ajoute de l'eau salée à de
l'eau douce non car l'eau est également
un milieu parfaitement transparent et
accessoirement 7 passes et opaque dans
un milieu clos ou bien l'air les ondes
lumineuses se propage de la même manière
qu'elles arrivent par ici ou par là ou
bien par ici et même par là ainsi pour
les scientifiques ces milieux sont dits
iso trop iso c'est une fille même trope
direction sachez que l'analyse de la
structure des objets isotrope a
longtemps posé problème aux
scientifiques
mais vous l'aurez deviné ils ont trouvé
une solution particulièrement astucieuse
est esthétique
il s'agit d'une observation en contraste
inférentielle à polarisation ou plus
simplement il n'y a pas plus simple il
s'agit de l'observation
en contraste interférences elle attend
la rizza chien
[Musique]
regardez ces images produites dans les
laboratoires de l'institut d'optique
théorique et appliquée
ce que vous venez de voir c'est la
surface de l'eau qui se déforme en
présence d'une tige et ses images
psychédéliques ont été obtenus grâce à
l'imagerie en contraste interférences
yen à polarisation comment fonctionne
cette surprenante techniques comme son
nom l'indiqué les contrastes de couleurs
sont obtenus suite à l'interférence de
la lumière rappeler la lumière blanche
se décompose en longueur d'onde qui
elles sont responsables des couleurs que
nous percevons lorsqu un rayon lumineux
travers certains cristaux comme le
quartz et se sépare en deux rayons
si avant ce cristal en place un objet
son image va se dédoubler et l'une de
ces images sera un peu ralenti par
rapport à l'autre les rues mineuse
produits vont alors pouvoir à interférer
cela signifie qu'elles montrent
interagir pour créer des ondes
lumineuses soit avec une plus grande
intensité et on appelle cela un
d'inférence constructive soit avec une
plus faible intensité et on appelle ça
des interférences destructive
l'éclairage se fait en lumière blanche
donc avec toutes les couleurs
certaines couleurs interfèrent
constructivement d'autres destructive
autrement dit certaines couleurs vont
disparaître alors que d'autres vont
rester et quand les types de la
polarisation me direz vous eh bien nous
n'allons pas rentrer dans les détails
mais sachez que la polarisation est une
propriété particulière de la lumière qui
est en quelque sorte filtrer par le
cristal pour donner les deux images à la
sortie cette technique ne permet de
visualiser des objets à faible contraste
ou des variations d'épaisseur d'objets
transparent un exemple chers amis
trouvaient donc une plaque de verre
le verre est parfaitement transparent et
parfaitement lisse en apparence
[Musique]
pourriez vous bouger légèrement l'accord
voyez les infimes d'irrégularités
d'épaisseur se traduisent par de vives
couleurs
merci mon ami maintenant prenez donc une
bougie
cette technique permet également de
visualiser les mouvements de l'air
observons les courants de convection
autour de la flamme de la bougie
[Musique]
et
un veau c'est très réussi et ce n'est
pas tout cette technique permet aux
chercheurs d'étudier nombre d'autres
phénomènes comme par exemple la
flottaison de petits animaux à la
surface de l'eau qui ne s'est jamais ému
face aux prouesses gracieuse de ces
petits insectes qui dans sa surface de
l'étang dans une chorégraphie donc
silencieuse qu'improviser comme vous
avez pu le voir nos chercheurs ont
réussi à rendre cette observation encore
plus magique grâce aux contrastes de
couleurs obtenues suite à l'interférence
de la lumière
cette technique est donc d'une très
grande utilité pour les biologistes les
physiciens qui étudie la mécanique des
fluides et bien évidemment les artistes
qui désignait à voir le monde autrement
ainsi ce n'est pas un hasard si imagerie
en contraste inférentielle à
polarisation rime avec poésie fonds
basque est essentielle à la
vulgarisation
[Applaudissements]
et pouf aux abonnés c'est par là et par
là aussi
également parrain et par là
[Musique]